>> Here's a skeleton of the al, of an algorithm that implements
a, a GA. So, [COUGH] what we need to do is we
start off with some inital population and usually the population size is
fixed to some constant. We'll call it K. So we just generate
a bunch of, of random individuals to get things started. Then what
we're going to do is we're going to repeat until essentially things
converge. We're going to compute the fitness of all of the individuals
in the population. And then we're going to select the most fit individuals.
So, how do you suppose we might decide on which ones are the most fit?
>> The ones you're most likely to go to the prom with?
>> Some people choose people differently than
just whether they're fit. I guess it
depends what you mean by fit. Do you mean like fit, like physical fitness?
>> Well, I meant fit like well, I did. But I
guess fit, like, whatever the fitness function tells you is fit.
>> Great! Okay, so, since we applied the
fitness function f to all the individuals we
have scores for them, and if we want to
select the ones that are most fit, which ones
do you think those would be? I guess you're
saying those would be the ones with the highest scores.
>> Yeah.
>> So that is, that's definitely one way to do it, where what happens is
you take the, say, top half of the population in terms of their scores, and we
declare them to be the most fit and everybody else to be the least fit. But
there's other ways you can do it as
well. One, this is sometimes called truncation selection.
But there's also an idea called roulette wheel selection where what you
do is you actually select individuals at random but you give the higher
scoring individuals a higher probability of actually being selected. So we don't
just strictly choose the best ones, we choose weighted by who's the best.
>> So does this get back to exploitation versus exploration then?
>> I think it does. I think it, I was
certainly having that thought when I was saying it out loud.
That this is a, it's a similar kind of
idea and in fact you can use Boltzmann distribution type
ideas similar to the annealing type idea for doing this
selection where you have a temperature parameter. If you set
the temperature parameter to zero then you get something
like just choosing the top half. And if you set
the temperature to be something like infinity then you're just
going to randomly choose samples from the population irregardless, no.
>> Irregardless is a word.
>> Is
it really?
>> Yes it's actually a word.
>> Irrespective is what I wanted to
say. Irrespective of the fitness of those individuals.
>> Well irregardless I understand what you mean.
>> Alright, so then that's going to, we declare some of them as most
fit. Then what we're going to do is pair up those most fit individuals. This
is like a dating service now. And
let them produce offspring using crossover and maybe
a little bit of mutation to. So instead of just taking the combination of the
two parent individuals, we take their combination and then we make
little, little local changes to it, to mute, mutate them. And
we let that, the, the value of that pair that, that
new offspring replace one of the least fit individuals in the population.
>> So Michael, can I ask you a question?
>> Sure.
>> I'm having a hard time what is
crossover means. Can you draw me a little picture?
>> Sure. That we, this might be, you know rated R.
>> That's fine.
>> No, no, no. No, you're right because we're going to do it well
so, it turns out that this is sort of generic, we can define crossover in
many different ways. But I think you're
right, I think it's worth looking at some
concrete examples because it gives you some
insight into why this operation might be useful.
>> Okay.